un marseille un ancien restaurant
mcdonald's transformer en plateforme
solidaire par ses anciens salariés il va
bénéficier d'un soutien solide de la
municipalité
menacé d'expulsion depuis des mois les
bénévoles de la pme sont maintenant
soulagé le projet social a déjà aidé
plus de 250000 personnes avec une
distribution quotidienne de 1200 colis
alimentaires et pourtant en attendant
l'acte officiel de rachat par le conseil
municipal prévue le 9 juillet tout
semble encore à faire louis kieffer à
l'intérieur du restaurant les provisions
arrive par palettes les sacs sont bien
remplies et les bénévoles ne relâchent
pas leurs efforts dehors la file
d'attenté non plus ne réduit pas dans ce
quartier
l'ancien fast food était un symbole
depuis plusieurs mois grâce à la mairie
de marseille
il devrait continuer à être un bastion
de la lutte contre la pauvreté
si les élus se félicitent d'avoir
soutenu le projet l'heure est venue de
le concrétiser selon eux la prennent
déjà ça a été un projet k qui a fait
beaucoup parler c'est vrai que la
nouvelle majorité municipale s'est
engagé à recoudre la ville et là on
était sur un exemple en fait sur une
belle histoire en fait dans des
quartiers qu'ils ont et étant
abandonnées enfin il se passait quelque
chose
et donc maintenant tout est à construire
effectivement lasser on a garanti le
fait que ne soit pas déposséder en fait
de ce lieu aujourd'hui en garantie la
ville 40e' le fait que ce lieu puisse
être transformée donc en un lieu
solidaire mais tout reste à construire
en termes de dynamique en termes de
gouvernance en fait de ce projet pour y
parvenir les bénévoles ont décidé de
créer l'association la part du peuple
débarrassé de la menace d'une expulsion
les premiers fonds récoltés devraient
permettre de démarrer l'activité du site
la richesse on veut la partager avec les
puces
et on souhaite que dans ce curieux là
qu'ils puissent reprendre un sens
économique qu'elle est salariée quand y
travailleront ici ils seront pour qui
travailler et pourquoi ils travaillent
et la richesse ou le bénéfice qui
dégagera ce restaurant avec des rats
pour les colis alimentaires
il ira pour nos amis de la rue des sans
abri et on répondra
nous sommes là en tant que citoyen pour
pouvoir aider notre vie pour une fois
cdd et des politiques qui vous qu'ils se
mettent au service des habitants d'un
quartier et ça s'est très très bien
maintenant il faut pas que ça empêche le
projet de continuer donc on va devoir
discuter avec la ville la convaincre que
notre projet c'est le bon projet
l'association envisage de créer 37
emplois pour lancer une activité de
restauration solidaire ouvrir une
cuisine ouverte en libre-service livrer
des paniers aux personnes à mobilité
réduite et enfin proposer une solution
écologique en circuit court avec des
achats de produits locaux